Adu dans la
BEL capitaine bien comme vous devez le
savoir demain il y aura une éclipse de
soleil non si ce qui n'arrivve pas tous
les jours vous ferez partir les hommes à
5h pour le terrain de manœuvre en de
campagne et et je leur donnerai d' pour
voir ce phénomène bien entendu et je
leur donnerai d' monticule les
effications nécessaires s'il pleut n aur
rien à voir dans ce cas vous laissez les
hommes dans la chambrée
romp c'est je mousqueton
oui écoutez écoutez-moi bien oui par
ordre du capitaine demain matin 5h il y
aura une éclipse de soleil en tenue de
campagne et le capitaine donnera d'un
monticule les explications nécessairesz
s'il ple il y aura rien à voir et ce
rare phénomène aura lieu dans la chambre
c'est pas croyable
[Musique]
nonoral
bazoua chef oui voilà attendez que je
me'y retrouve ah oui alors demain demain
le ah oui c'est ça demain le capitaine
fera éclipser le soleil en du de
campagne avec les explications
nécessaires sur les terrains de manœuvre
du monticu voilà alors s pleuvait ce
rare phénomène qui n'a rien à voir
là-dedans aurait lieu dans la
chambré qu'est-ce qu'ils vont pas
chercher hein allez allez romp e les
gars approchez-vous un peu dis amène toi
toi oui attend attends vous êtes tous là
écoutez ça un peu c'est terrible demain
matin 5h il y a le soleil le soleil du
terrain de manœuvre qui fera éclipser un
capitaine qui s'appelle
monte attends s pleit il rien à voir et
ce rare phénomène aurait lieu en tenue
de campagne on voit pas ça tous les
jours hein allez r
pasroupement e e e la
bellure viens voirens qu'est-ce qu'il a
dit le caporal j'ai rien compris il il a
dit que le capitaine il avait vu à 5h du
matin un drôle de phénomène dans sa
chambrée
et le gars il s'est tiré qu il a vu le
capitaine parce que ça y allait à la
manœuvre ah oui et alors le gars il
s'est tirait il était en petite tenue il
courit à la campagne en faisant des
bon qui c'est-il ce phénomène
qui çaelle va être une
gonzesse
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]